um uh likewise also also that women
should Adorn themselves in respectable
apparel with modesty and self-control
not with braided hair and gold or per or
pearls or costly attire let me explain
what he doesn't mean here he's not
saying you can have gold he's me he's
saying the emphasis is not on your
external appearance because gold is not
what's going to give you true lasting
beauty or braided hair so it's not it's
he's not saying it's a sent that braided
hair but he's saying that true be in the
sight of God that lasts is not external
it's not the way you dress it's not your
jewelry or your hair and ladies take
that to heart because if you have true
inner beauty when you get old and
Raggedy and you got layers of fat but if
you're still a beautiful godly woman the
man will still love you because unlike
Men We Men age it's a truth right men
who take care of themselves age fine the
older we get the better looking we
become I mean look at me I'm much more
gorgeous when I was in20 but you ladies
you're fighting every second to retain
that little ounce of beauty that is
fading with your wrinkles and all your
Bo Botox ain't happening baby but anyway
go ahead keep
R but with what is proper for women who
Pro who profess godliness with good
works let women learn quietly with all
submissiveness I do not permit a woman
to teach or to exercise authority over a
man now what he means by this is woman
can not lead the church a mixed
congregation you this by the way I know
it's going to hurt a lot of people I'm
sorry to say this for those of you who
are probably going to get upset if
you're going to let the Bible speak and
not pervert the Bible and try to just
brush this this off as something
cultural women cannot be Bishops of a
mixed
congregation so Joyce smer
bye-bye right I'm just letting you know
in the congregation Bishops are
males born males not made males no
transgenders male Bishops and when you
have a male Bishop then the woman will
be assigned responsibilities by a male
Bishop that's why in the early church
you could have female
deacons female deacons right so just let
you know that's what Paul says but
people try to explain this way well Paul
was thought cultur oh there was a heresy
and Paul was a shut up keep on
um for Adam was formed first then Eve
and Adam was not deceived but the woman
was deceived and became a
transgressor yet she will be yet she
will be saved through childbearing did
you skip something no did okay I thought
you did because okay Eve the part of Eve
repeat the part of Eve again Adam was
not deceived but the woman was deceived
and became a transgressor hold on
Journey wait wait wait wait Journey's
upset one second Journey why only man
Bishop one second hold on brother hold
on hold on she's upset uh Journey are
you a
female you're upset I to
call I got a direct connection to heaven
hold on joury G send you on your journey
in a minute hold on hold on hold on here
you go joury see I got a direct ly to
Heaven hold on journey journey saying
why only men okay hold on
secondy rafhael what's up Rafi baby man
I haven't spoken to you in a man can I
ask you a question is Paul there uh oh
hold on Katy I'm talking I'm sorry
what's up Paulie Paulie yo yo yo what I
Paul can I ask you a question we got
Journey bu uh why only male Bishops Paul
what's wrong with you you're lucky
you're not born right now because social
media would have banned you from Twitter
Instagram you couldn't preach anymore
how about that
huh oh that's why because the bishop
stands in the place of Jesus Jesus is
the husband of the church not the wife
of the church so it makes no sense that
you'll have a female representing the
role of a husband unless we're all
transgenders and all for homosexuality
wow what a wisdom
Paul man Paul you are a genius so the
reason why the the Bishops are males
because the bishop is standing in place
of Christ and Christ is the husband not
the wife so it makes no sense to have a
female representing a husband Paul can I
kiss your bald
head better than smooching the black
stone baby all right sh I'll talk to you
later so joury did you like that
answer you want to represent Jesus the
husband when you're a
woman do you want to okay Journey now
Journey please tell me you're a woman
tell me that you're a woman I just want
to know if you're a woman before I move
on see I figure I figured it's only a
woman that complain well I it got to be
on me hand that's not fair because in my
household my husband wears my dresses
we're equal he wears my dress and I wear
his pants and even colors his toenails
black how about that see we're equal and
when I get pregnant he gives birth okay
I get pregnant he gives birth okay
that's not fair
Sammy oh you
are all right okay now let's let's
continue yeah keep going okay so um and
Adam was not deceived but the woman was
deceived and became a transgressor yet
she will be saved through childbearing
if they continue in faith and love and
Holiness with self-control yeah yeah so
you read all the way to 15 yep okay the
question is what does it mean that a
woman will be saved because of child
rearing child
birthing read that part again so they
can see read that part again she'll be
saved
why uh she'll be saved through
childbearing if they continue in faith
and love and Holiness with self-control
okay what does that mean how can she be
saved through
childbearing provided she remains
faithful to the Lord and controls
herself to the end well number one let's
see how a person is saved according to
Paul go to 1 Timothy 1 1 Timothy 1 and
read verse 16 read 15 and 16 1 Timothy 1
15- 16 yeah yeah but I received Mercy
from for this reason that is that that
me as the foremost uh Jesus Christ might
display his perfect patience as an
example to those who were who were to
believe in him for eternal life so how
are you granted eternal
life uh you're granted eternal life by
believing in him so believing in him
believing in Jesus Christ trusting in
Jesus Christ is what brings about
eternal life right amen yeah now go to
Second Timothy 3 read verse
15 second Timothy 3 ver yeah
be careful Sonia when you say the yes of
Mary because that means if Mary said no
that means it was over for God and
creation is going to go to hell be
careful Sonia just I know what you mean
Sonia but articulate in a way so you
don't be accused of trying to worship
Mary and make her into a goddess be
careful how you say it because there
other people are not going to understand
what you mean I know what you mean
others won't understand what you mean
but I'm going to tie it in with what you
just said but just be careful how you
articulate your position because you
have enemies are going to take your
words to slander you but now go ahead
read second Timothy
3:15 uh and how from childhood you have
been acquainted with the sacred writings
which are able to make you wise for
salvation through faith in Christ Jesus
so how are you saved how do you receive
eternal life according to
Paul uh hold on one sec oh no sorry and
how from by being acquainted with the
sacred
writings and having faith in Christ
Jesus right so how do you obtain
salvation eternal
life by firmly believing and well it's
right in front of you you just read it
how are you saved man read it for me
through faith in Jesus Christ there you
got it Jes so in 1 timothy6 you obtain
eternal life through faith believing in
Jesus you obtain salvation here through
faith in Jesus Christ right yeah now if
a woman believes in Jesus Christ truly
believes is that faith something you say
and Ascent to or is it a living faith
that most necessarily will result in a
transformed life producing fruits of
obedience exactly what you said so yeah
so when Paul says that a woman will be
saved through child rearing what he
means is if you are truly a Godly woman
who trusts in Jesus you're going to live
out your faith in obedience and that
obedience is the necessary fruit the
necessary result of trust ing in Christ
for eternal life because there's no such
thing as saying you believe in Jesus and
living recklessly and in Disobedience so
a woman who devotes herself to Godliness
and doing what God wants her to do raise
up a Godly family that is a woman who's
truly a woman after God's heart and she
will be given salvation on the day of
salvation amen okay so that's one
meaning now there's another meaning
which ties them with what sun is saying
are you ready for the other meaning yeah
now everyone understood that what I just
said guys understood what it means that
a woman will be saved through child
rearing he's not saying it's the good
works by themselves no it's saying if
you're truly a godly woman in love with
Jesus transformed by Jesus you must
necessarily obey the Lord because that's
a necessary fruit so that obedience is
obedience that grants you or I should
say that obedience is not only the fruit
of salvation but it's that obedience
that keeps you saved in Union with
Christ that's why he says you remain
faithful to the end CU if you walk away
you'll be cut
off so there is no such thing as someone
tell me I believe in Jesus and has sex
before marriage or justifies abortion or
transgenderism or homosexuality or
Rebellion that's not the sign of someone
who is saved through faith in Christ
will obtain eternal life when the Lord
comes exactly yeah okay so that's what
he's saying now there's a second meaning
a second meaning notice the context is
talking about Eve right now I hope I'm
not confusing you guys guys and I'm
trusting the spirit to save me from
error I'm trying to speak as clearly as
I can in the context he's already
mentioned Eve now some believe because
he's mentioning Eve he is referring back
to the seed of the woman he's mentioning
Eve deceived by the serpent so the woman
gives birth to a child is not any woman
it is a reference to the promise given
that the seed of the woman would come
and save us so what Paul is actually
saying is it's the child born of that
woman Jesus born of Mary that will save
you if remain faithful to him till the
end and that's what Sonia was trying to
say you went me
there I don't know if you're there did I
lose
you I think I lost this
guy oh no sorry I'm back I was just
talking to my family oh but my my dad
came down and he was like he was talking
getting orders giving orders to me did
you hear what I just said what child
birth is it referring to
um it's referring to it was about Eve
when it talks about Eve was deceived
what did God promise Eve in Genesis 3
when he said to the serpent I'll put
hatred between you and who the woman
right woman and then between your seed
and her seed so notice he says the woman
gives birth to a child so he may be
referring to the promise given to Eve
that the woman will give birth to a
child and that's the child who will save
you if you remain faithful to him till
the
end yeah
okay you with me there did you get it
you sure yeah I I got what you mean okay
so you see a reference to Eve and her
being tempted to sin which will
then bring to mind the promise that the
seed of the woman will crush the serpent
so when he says the woman will be saved
through childbearing he may be referring
to that woman who gives birth to that
specific child who saves you and that
child would be Jesus the son of Mary
okay yeah that's why it says provided
you remain remain faithful faithful to
to the child that the woman gave birth
to so either interpretation fits
contextually you with me you sure you
got distracted again was it now did
Mommy distract you now no no no I was
listening I was listening okay so you
understood now are you sure yeah okay
the point from Genesis 3:15 you made yes
the connection okay so that's the
connection that specific child birth
that woman who gives birth to a child
the seed who crushes the serpent to save
us and that would be Jesus so he's
saying you'll be saved through the woman
that gives birth to the child meaning
Mary who's given birth to the child so
that if you remain faithful to that
child whom the woman has given birth to
Jesus you'll be
saved so either interpretation fits the
context right yeah right either either
interpretation yeah it's the woman
believer who performs her duties proving
that she truly believes and she's not
lips service because if you truly
believe there's necessary transformation
fruits of obedience and those fruits of
obedience are necessary to maintain your
righteous standing before Christ that's
why he says you have to remain faithful
so it can be referring to the woman's
responsibility in doing what Jesus
commands her to do and if she does she
has the assurance that when he comes
she'll be rewarded with salvation not
judgment Andor it may be referring to
the woman whose seed crushes the serpent
Mary and her seed the Lord Jesus Christ
clear yes could I hope that answered
your two questions